what you find with these geometry
puzzles if you like is that really it's
about like what's you phrase a question
algebra when I said like a probable
phrase is from half solved right except
your phrasing like there's no word to
you it's all about like what what
constructions do you promise to you to
make it clear right I only put on I'll
just double check you yeah I put on two
lines two eyes there are simple lines as
well okay they take advantage of the
fact that there's one
these are the early constructions that
I'm going to place on my diagram and I
needed to know the fact that you see
you've gone up this big thing is a big
quadrant okay then you've got two
semicircles here and the point when they
meet appointment I mean because this is
a big quadrant like this semicircle this
step is talk about the same diameter
right which means they meet here and
this radius and this radius are each the
tangent of the other semicircle we said
it again in case you dismiss it is in
case you missed it this radius of the
left-hand circle right is tangent to
this semicircle here at the bottom so I
have a whole bunch of right angles in
here right
critically I have a right angle here
right and I'm a right angle here because
of these are these things in quadrants
okay so now let's have a go at this the
first thing I see is that this time here
your radius radius all these right
angles it's a square right it's a square
I need some language I haven't given you
any length so you don't know the size of
this thing
so I'm just going to call the radius of
this semicircle ah for radius okay we'll
let that be the radius so therefore the
step one is what's the area of the
square simple question it's just a
square
that's easy enough okay now to work out
what the area of this orange part a one
is right I need to know what this pot is
so I'm gonna call it area three okay
I'll go to area one area is my third one
how do I want to cut the area of that
there are your three in there it's on
it's gonna be the square what do I take
away I take away this little quadrant in
here not the big quadrant there's a
little quadrant here okay so I'll call
that the area of the small quadrant is
that okay
the area is 1/4 1/4 it is 1/4 of a
circle and I called the radius of that
circle ah so it's 1/4 of pi r-squared
you go that okay so now to work out the
third area
alright the third area is the square
take away that small quadrant right so
it's just R squared by this 1/4 PI R
squared did you have doing that ok so
now I'm only one step away from working
out what the orange area is what area
one is area one is going to be its
square is the square what do I have to
take away from this way to get one yeah
two of these guys right so it's a square
take away two of this guy right this not
quadrant part so that's R squared minus
1/4 PI R squared yep when i tidy that
thing up that's gonna become minus 2 r
squared so that will be minus r squared
there and then this guy here's a doll
negative and that's being doubled so i'm
gonna get 1/2 squared out the front you
happy with that so now I need to work
out this big area up here
okay this big area there's a few
different ways I can do this okay
probably the easiest way is to say okay
this um this whole big quadrant right
the big quadruped area of the
or drew remembering that I've said this
is AMA okay what's the radius of the big
quadrant it's two are good and the
quadrant is of course a quarter of a
circle so it's going to be 1/4 PI 2 R
that's the radius of that big quadruped
square are you doing that ok so this is
going to be 4 R square for R squared is
it a quarter there this is actually just
playoffs where you can with that all
right now how do I get area to now it's
going to be this large quadrant large
quicker what do I have to take away from
the large quadrant in order to only
leave me with the green part okay so
make sure you go to carefully
overlapping stuff yeah yeah good very
good square right plus quadruples
quadrant and two quadrants of course is
just a semicircle right so it's there's
the big quadrant I'm gonna take away the
square okay and then I'm gonna take away
a semicircle right 1/2 PI R squared
yeah which is this and these are like
terms which are going to leave me with
that which of course is a 1 as required
ok it's a beautiful little result